hello everybody I would like to welcome
you to my conversation with Rachel
Fulton Brown we had a conversation I
think was it about a year and a half ago
now I think and I would say that she is
probably one of the people that I've
been asked the most to have back on the
channel especially considering some of
the discussions that I've been trying to
have about feminine symbolism and its
place in Christianity and we talked we
touched a little bit about that last
time in our talk and I'm hoping that we
can dive into it a lot more in this
discussion today
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
I'm so happy to be back so you've been
first of all maybe in just a few minutes
you've been quite busy in the past since
about a year and a half you've also had
this flurry around you
I get the feeling oh I hope that it's
kind of calmed down maybe you can tell
us where you're standing right now
terms of your position and the
controversy that's been kind of swimming
around you oh do we have to talk about
that let's talk about symbolism okay I
will just I will say Milo there you go
okay let's talk about symbolism all
right okay so let's talk about that's my
preference that's my favorite subject
anyways and so as all of you know we've
been Ivan for the past I would say six
maybe three four months I've been making
an effort to give some framework and
talk about feminine symbolism I've I put
out a video talking about the place of
the mother of God in art kind of the
development of her imagery I've also put
out some videos talking about popular
culture and how we have these strange
tensions in the representation of
feminine symbolism and so I know that
you know rachel has written this book
just recently about about the place of
Mary in medieval worship and so I
thought she would be a great partner to
talk about this so maybe maybe you can
tell me a little bit about I mean I know
you watch my video so I'm saying and you
said you're eager to talk so let's let's
see what you have to say to start out
with well my first thing is you're very
dear you're completely right about the
symbolism of Mary that I I and and what
I'm encouraged by is that what have you
read my book because it sounds like I
have I have not well but that that's
even better because you're talking about
Mary is the place where God becomes
present and that's exactly what I'm
showing in my Mary in the art of prayer
that in the Western tradition I know
you're usually working with the icons
and the eastern tradition but that's
what's wonderful about it that in the
Western tradition which is drawing on
the eastern imagery that is her primary
characteristic right she is I think you
talked about it in your in your lecture
she's the temple
and she's also all of the other places
in which God manifests his presence you
mentioned I think the Ark
she's the burning bush she's the cloud
that leads the Israelites as they're
moving through the desert
she's the the all the different
furniture of the temple right she could
be the the Holy of Holies most
intimately because that's the place
where the Ark is kept and therefore
that's where God becomes present in her
she's also in in the in this this
interpretive tradition the the city of
Jerusalem itself so often say the the
image of the heavenly bride in
Revelation is read as heard that this is
this is or the relationship between her
and and Christ
she's the Tree of Life that standing
beside the throne because as the mother
she stands beside the throne
um that her son sits on she sent throne
that her son sits on she's the holy
mountain and it expands out am I in my
book I go through a lot of it is a very
long list right if you're going to
describe what it means to think about
the Incarnation to say God entered into
his creation through Mary in effect you
end up having to describe the whole of
creation because you're trying to
describe the way in which she contained
in her womb he the one whom the heavens
themselves could not contain and so
ultimately what she is this heaven and I
I think you in your lecture you did a
lovely job of showing that that in the
icon in the Orthodox iconography she's
always shown framing Christ that she is
the one who frames and presents her son
to the world she is the one who shows
him to the world because he becomes
incarnate through her but that this
mystery becomes cosmic because he is the
creator of the world into it he enters
through her so I maybe you don't need to
read my book it's already there well I
really do take I mean I really do take
what I know of the mother of god from
the iconographic tradition plus also the
the hymnography and the services in the
Orthodox Church the way that we speak
about her
in that tradition so I think that like
you said I think that in terms of the
symbolism
I'm sure there's perfect alignment
because especially you know I'd say in
the first 1,000 years or maybe the first
twelve hundred years you you you know
you really had the same a very similar
mindset in terms of how to read
scripture and how to see the Incarnation
so what I say could I say something on
that yes
so as the historian right to say it's
not just that it's the same tradition
it's people are reading each other right
it's the the Orthodox the Eastern
Orthodox sources are the direct the
direct source of the Western devotion
and that that's something that we
sometimes talk about the Catholic Church
which doesn't technically exist until
the 16th century it's just christened
the Latin Church we talk about the Latin
Church in the Greek Church as if they're
never talking to each other and and the
reality is I mean it's very interesting
particularly in the descriptions of the
mother of God it's it's it's the same
tradition it's not two different
traditions that happen to be parallel
it's the same tradition so particularly
that that in my book I talk in Chapter
three about the way in which the West
picks up that the Greek imagery that
much of the Greek imagery which if
you're saying you're getting it from the
iconography from the liturgy that the
most important sources are of course the
the hymns and and things that are sung
about her so the akathistos hymn the
akathistos is translated into Latin in
the ninth century so it's completely
available to the west right all of that
wonderful cascade of titles that's in
the akka thesis is known in the West
likewise the homilies that the great 8th
century homilies that are written for
the marian feasts by andrew of crete and
Germanness of constantinople and john of
damascus those are those are known in
the West they're translated in the West
Andrew Crete is is certainly known in
Rome because in the 7th the 7th and 8th
centuries it at the very time when the
liturgies are being developed for the
the marian feasts but many of the pups
are from the east right they're Syrian
Greek and they bring with them this this
marian tradition we know
oh that from 687 in in Rome that all of
the the Feast of the Virgin are
commemorated with a great procession and
we could talk about the procession and
the way the imagery is used there but
they're that they're known in the West
adopted in the West directly from the
Orthodox tradition so it's it's not a
coincidence or just a you know sort of
simple parallel it's the same tradition
okay that's very interesting to me
because I like I did not know at all the
historical manner in which it's
developed I just look at the images I
look at the the art and I look at the
you know I listen to the hymnography and
I say okay yeah this is the same right I
think that that linked to the fact that
like you said I mean I knew in theory
that a lot of the Popes the early folks
actually came from the east but I didn't
hit me that then yeah obviously they
would bring with them
this whole liturgical tradition but up+
also like you said the writings the
homilies all this development of the
imagery of the mother of god so that
that's they're very fascinating to me
that's for certain
so even even the things like you in in
the West they're Archer there are
different devotional traditions and it
would be interesting to talk about those
if you want to but in the West that what
my book is about is the hours of the
Virgin which is a particularly Western
tradition that it's modeled on the
Divine Office that the the monks and
nuns would say but it's basically a
cycle of Psalms that are recited well in
addition to the regular office but a
cycle of Psalms that are recited in
honor of Mary but the framing imagery is
is quite powerful there and that's what
I try to show in my book that the that
the chance that are describing Mary in
the Marian office like blessed art thou
among women blesses the fruit of thy
womb musically frame the chanting of the
psalms so that that anta phone blessed
art thou among women and blessed is the
fruit of thy womb frames the recitation
of psalm eight which is a description of
creation right so it's it's it's it's
it's it's sort of musically and an aura
verbally in words reproducing the
imagery that you're talking about right
she's shown as framing him in the in the
iconography in the chant the
the the chant that describes her frames
the chant that describes God and and
that's replicated throughout the office
um that is a practice that's particular
to the West but the choice of the Psalms
depends on the imagery that's used in
the liturgy in the East and that's what
I show that the Psalms that they choose
in the West to say in this Marian office
are the ones that the eastern Hama lists
drawn the most to describe her so it's
it's it's a wonderfully married
tradition yeah one of the things that
that I try to help people understand
especially people who are coming from
the Protestant tradition who really
struggle with the imagery of the mother
of God and I totally understand it I
mean I think that as a Protestant myself
that was the first know the emotional
kind of reaction when you see some of
the things but as you start to analyze
the hymns and you start to analyze even
the longer prayers or the or the
services which kind of are more have a
more Marian theme you see this movement
the movement that you just mentioned in
the antiphon which is blessed art thou
amongst women blessed is the fruit of
your womb it's always this you always
have this movement from the outside
towards the inside you have the movement
from the space to let's say the the
definer of the space from so you always
kind of move from from let's say the
space of the revelation to the
revelation itself I mean that's
something that I've seen as a structure
and so it is it is kind of this like
elevation of the space of the space of
manifestation because it's full of glory
that you know it is it is in a way the
way that by which we're able to see what
you know the divine manifesting itself
and then there's this like rise up
towards praising God himself praising
Christ and praising praising through
Christ praising God so it's always this
movement or moving moving up it never
stays at this because people are afraid
that somehow we're treating the mother
of God as if as if she's got herself
exactly I've been having lots of long
conversations in my facebook on that
because people have come and friended me
for lots of different reasons and and
some of them are because I'm i lo
and others because they're Catholics and
it's very interesting to me to see the
tensions there that there's this fear I
mean the Protestants are really often
quite afraid that we are worshipping
Mary and and it doesn't matter it seems
curious that the you know the Catholics
I don't have I need some more Orthodox
friends but the Catholics are saying no
we don't she is the one who you know
helps us see God right and in the in the
tradition I'm writing about in the in
the Middle Ages it's it's not just
physically that she helps us see God in
incarnation right that's the whole
iconic the whole iconographic tradition
that you work in depends on that
understanding that as John is Damascus
is saying like you can the the image
points to the prototype you can only
make images of Christ because of the
Incarnation right otherwise you don't
have you can't represent the divine
visually because there's no
visualization but the same thing in the
in the Latin tradition is that she is
also holding God in her mind right she's
the model contemplative because I mean
as she hold things in her heart and she
understands Christ as she she lives with
him in his earthly life you talked in
your lecture about how she's at the
marriage of Cana sort of nudging him and
I'd like to talk about that nudging him
to to to know perform his first sign
that she is the one who directs the
contemplation to God as well so all of
it is all it's both in the Incarnation
and in the understanding of his divinity
that she's a creature who points us to
the Creator that's that's her primary
her primary mystery yeah and there is I
think that also in the movement this is
something that I that I've been thinking
about a lot in the movement of the hymns
around the mother of God and the man in
which we speak of her in the manner to
which we we celebrate her you can see
the proper movement from creation to the
Creator because one of the problems that
you get that I remember even
experiencing that in in the in the
Protestant church where they say you
only we only worship God we only worship
God we don't we don't worship anything
in creation but because they because
they
had this strange they don't they're not
able to see how you move that way then
you have strange moments like in church
when somebody that say somebody does a
sings a song and then people clap like
right okay so what are you what are you
clapping - what are you clapping - the
person who who sang because if you're
doing that then you are set you're
you're worshiping you're that person but
you don't have the property ology to
understand how you can move up like how
you can handle the other that
celebration of what you saw up towards
the Creator how you can both celebrate
the vehicle the vehicle of manifestation
and and move towards the towards the
creator himself but in that I think that
the movement that we experience through
encountering the mother of God and and
moving towards the the Incarnation
that's the proper movement and can help
us understand how we can interact with
creation and the creator you know all
all in this celebratory manner yes
anyway that's just something that I've
been thinking about so much because I I
mean even when I remember even I was
when I was Protestant I had that I kind
of had that that problem when it's and I
reven remember in some churches they
would say things like oh we shouldn't
clap because they knew the problem they
understood the problem of celebrating
congroo you know celebrating something
that's happening but then not knowing
how that moves up towards not any this
kind of hierarchy of how it moves up
towards the the creator so there's so
there's another way I've tried to argue
you for Protestants since it's both you
and I are converts right that I was a
Presbyterian until recently when I
entered the the Catholic Church but I
obviously been I've been studying Mary
now for 30 years right and what I'm
interested by is I studied Mary as a
Protestant in effect because what I have
been working on is the the exegesis
right the scriptural interpretation and
the liturgy and the ways in which in
medieval Christianity the scriptures
were understood to speak about Mary so I
really started from a very Presbyterian
place it's like I need to understand
what the scriptures say and I think we
talked about some of this and maybe
in our first video possibly but just to
remember to reiterate that my first my
first book is on the commentary on on
the Song of Songs and the ways in which
the Song of Songs is used in the Marian
liturgy as a way of describing her
relationship with Christ her
relationship with her son as in the
mystery bride and bridegroom because
she's the bride of God but also very
intimately in their in their earthly
life because there's this I'm not sure
we want to go into this but in medieval
and Orthodox exegesis you understand
that the Scriptures speak on a number of
different levels right and so there's
the the story level the history there's
the moral level the the tropa logical
level the lessons that we get as souls
from the Scriptures and then there's the
allegorical level which is the mystery
of Christ and his relationship with his
church and the Song of Songs is read I
mean it's like God and Israel's so
that's the allegorical level it's Christ
in the church but there's also this this
interesting problem of well who is
Solomon in describing his relationship
with his love and if you read the Old
Testament as Christians do as always
patterning itself on Christ the Song of
Songs is also patterning his
relationship with with Mary who is his
his mother his bride his sister his love
his friend I mean all of those
relationships come into it and and so it
gives the medieval Christians a way of
imagining their conversation as it were
in this in the new book and we uncertain
that's just set off alarm bells for
everybody whereas in the new book I'm
showing as I said the way in which the
Psalms are understood to reveal this
kind of relationship and that matters
because of course the only reason the
only reason Christianity is Christianity
is because we recognize Christ Jesus as
the Lord and and therefore in the in the
Christian tradition we read the Psalms
as speaking about Christ so for example
on on Good Friday we we we chant Psalm
21 in the Septuagint numbering right you
just use the Septuagint number II not
just stick with that right good as in
fact Christ's words from the cross
because they were what Jesus said you
know my lord my lord why have you
forsaken me which is the psalmist's
exclamation so we take that as the
speaking of Christ that this this whole
exegetical tradition is the only way we
have access to the fully full
understanding of Christ as Lord but it's
similar that it's the way we have access
to Mary in his in her relationship with
him and if you're nervous about that
well Calvin does it too so it's
interesting that I think a lot of modern
Christians don't actually understand the
the exegetical tradition on which even
Protestantism depends no I agree I and I
think that recovering the this this
tradition is is so primordial to me I
mean that's that's what I've been I've
been like trying to do so much is trying
to help people see the manner in which
the Christ becomes the fulcrum and then
we look at these patterns in the Old
Testament as always manifesting let's
say the mystery of the Incarnation and
so it to me it makes so much sense that
in the Old Testament you do have this
this place for the let's say the the
manner in which you you contain or not
contained but let's say the temple the
the Ark all these vehicles of
manifestation and and they're very
important in the story and so the
question is once God becomes enters into
the personal story once
God is incarnate then that pattern must
continue the pattern must find its
resolution you could say and so then
what is the resolution to to that
pattern in the story of Christ it's
obvious that the resolution is Mary
because she she is the one who who had
him in his womb but also there are these
mysterious verses where it talks about
her you know gathering all these things
in her heart like this the gathering all
the all the things she sees in her heart
and and that is just also this image of
this this face
which gathers in and kind of shows you
the the the spark the divine spark let's
say and then then it also becomes the
the church it also becomes the believer
just a believer that the human person
ourselves that that in a certain way you
kind of vacillate between saying that
the mother of God is our hope because
she is the one who who had the Living
Christ inside her which is what we want
but we also aiming towards Christ
Himself which is when you know which is
the image of God himself and so you kind
of had this this vacillation between and
it's interesting because I always see in
the imagery of the mother of God it's
interesting that for example some images
they will be used the same images for
Christ
as for the mother of God and you can
understand it because you can understand
that each each image has a kind of
substance like a substance part which is
underneath and let's say a let's say a
or effeminate part of the masculine part
so the latter for example like Christ
will be described as a ladder as well
and and the mother of God will be
described as that ladder but there is
the ladder which is the that say the the
support for the movement and then
there's the actual ascent and descent
which is also the ladder I don't know if
I don't know if you you you see what I'm
going here I do because it she's the
mirror and and that's the the other
element of the scriptural tradition is
to appreciate that the marian tradition
depends on the Septuagint and that's why
the Orthodox tradition and it
particularly depends on the books of
wisdom wisdom and ecclesiasticus and
those are the those are the texts that
are used in addition to the song of
songs and the psalms to describe mary
and one of the most important passages
describing her is that she's this is
from wisdom 7 she's the mirror of his
majesty right so mary is the most she's
all of us as human beings are made in
the image and likeness of god but the
great mystery is of course she is the
most perfect creature ever made because
she was the one who contained him in her
womb he makes her to be his mother
which means she is the most perfect
reflection of God so all of that all
this is why means like she becomes most
like God that's what Dante describes her
that she has the face that is most like
Christ's and and in the Western art it's
like that the greater similarity you can
show between the two of them there's a
she's his mother so his flesh is her
flesh is his flesh as it were he gets
his flesh from her as a creature but she
is made so perfectly in His image she
reflects him most perfectly it makes
utter sense that all of that imagery in
and you you end up with this the
mirroring constantly right it's like you
see her you see him in her you see you
he you look at him you understand why
she so resembles him yeah and and in
that I think that one of the I would say
one of the the side effects of modernism
one of the side effects of the modern
age has been a kind of objectification
of creation or or made lack of capacity
to see in creation this this mysterious
space for the divine to manifest itself
and I wonder if you've thought a little
bit about the relationship let's say
with the changes in the way we we
understand are that the West is
understood an area especially in kind of
Germanic countries and and in Protestant
countries and that shift towards a
almost mechanistic vision yes yes i
think i think that that's what losing
mary means we lose the division of
reality that i think you have been
trying to describe in your lectures that
she meditating on her means you're
meditating on creation and you're and
you're meditating on the the sort of
what one you're you're suggesting the
proper relationship between art you know
ourselves and God God in creation but
you're also understanding the the
creature right and that's I was talking
about the different titles that Mary has
in the Middle Ages that she is if she's
heaven she's the Stars the Sun the Moon
the dawn you've talked about the dawn
bit that she's the earth she's the
mountain she's the rivers that's some
trees lots of trees those are all from
ecclesiasticus flowers
you're realizing that you're you're
looking for the signs of the Divine in
his artwork mm-hmm and that she points
you to that as well because you're
meditating on her through all of this
symbolism right if you're the rose the
lily the cedar of Lebanon the the palm
tree that the spices all of those things
you're in effect understanding that
creation is this great work of art and
if and and we seemed to you know that
the problem is you know how do you
contain God in your in your
understanding how does she contain God
in herself that ultimately becomes
encyclopedic right
but it becomes encyclopedic in this
understanding that you need to
understand the properties of all the
creatures in order to properly praise
her because in praising her you're
praising the creator yeah and and that
again it's that riff it's that that
wonderful that wonderful reflection that
that she reflects the creation she
reflects the beauty of I mean it's not
even nature right nature seems separate
and distant and we're not a part of it
she's she's the image of what it means
to be human in creation I don't know if
you know a little bit about the
controversy the the Orthodox controversy
surrounding the it's called sociology
have you do you know a little bit about
that story
yeah well not maybe directly but I've
been tangled up in it incurs a criticism
of my book okay well I think it's
important to I think it's if maybe we
can talk a little bit about that because
there is there was this move in the 20th
cent in the 20th century and I think you
can feel it also in in Catholicism a
little bit there's this move also in
orthodoxy to kind of push things further
in terms of the place that the mother of
God has an Orthodox Church there was a
theologian Bulgakov who who who tried to
link let's say the wisdom of God so
closely to to marry that to make her
almost like an incarnation of of Sophia
and and in the tradition end of the
patristic tradition there's a kind of
there's a shift because in patristic
tradition off
Sophy our wisdom of God is Christ like
that he's that it seemed that his Christ
was the wisdom of God but then in the
the text the wisdom is often described
as feminine and so there is I think that
the I think that the the best resolution
of that was is that image of the mother
of God with Christ on her on her lap
which is that is the best image of
Sophia in the sense that it is you know
it is the the wisdom of God sitting on
his throne but it's all one image like
it's all kind of goes together because
he gets his body from her and so there's
this kind of coming together but maybe
you can tell me a little bit about how
you got pulled into the this criticism
well because that's the way she's
described in the West in the in the
medieval tradition that she is sappy and
Seija but she's also macho sappy and CI
right she is she's wisdom and the mother
of wisdom and it one of the texts that I
talk about in depth in my book is
Richard of San Lawrence book on the
praises of the mother of Mary Dale out
of us well whatever um and um in his
preface he talks explicitly about this
mystery right that because she's the
most perfect reflection of him because
she's filled with him she you know
carries all wisdom and so that that that
twinning is again it we've been talking
about it already that she's always
creature right that is that is very very
clear in all of the Latin all of Latin
text she is his most perfect creature
but because she's so perfectly
mirroring him she becomes godlike and
you you've talked about that too in your
lectures that in the Orthodox tradition
we are you know theosis ism is a thing
right welcome she is most transformed
into the perfect reflection of the
divine and that includes as wisdom so in
the in the medieval tradition
particularly in the 13th century she's
the patron of the University of Paris
the Faculty of Arts because they
understand that because she contained
wisdom she contains wisdom right so she
contains all the language arts she
contains the quadrivium the mathematical
art she knows that you know all the
mysteries of theology she knows the
mysteries of the Angels we
is to say if you were filled with God
this is what you'd know and it's it's
it's complicated because back in the in
the early tradition developing her
liturgies drawing on the text where
wisdom speaks for example proverbs well
is that Christ ER is that his mother
well it's it's you have to you have to
play to sort of face pause game you know
the there's that that it's it's a what
do you call optical illusion right that
you have is that two faces or is it of
Oz right and and thinking about Mary and
imagery is often like that it's always
you know the faces show you the vaz of
Oz shows you the faces she is wisdom she
shows you wisdom he is wisdom
she contains him and so it's actually a
meaningless question
it automatically it's like which ones
which right I think that is we
understand I mean in all points of the
mystery of the Incarnation itself that
one of the reasons I think that wisdom
is portrayed also as feminine in the Old
Testament is because of this idea of
wisdom as this as the you know the the
presence of God in the world like like
like you were saying this kind of this
kind of so it is it can be first of all
even in the Old Testament it kind of
makes sense to have this it's kind of
underlying wisdom which is kind of under
the world it makes sense to represent it
as as feminine and then as we are the
body of Christ also we we are the Bride
of Christ we have on this whole there's
this whole eschatological aspect to it
which I keep telling people that the
problem with I think the problem with
sociology was that it was uttering
something which is eschatological and
was trying to utter it as if in a manner
which was not just leaving the mystery
of the eschatology to what extent we
will participate in God like to what
extent we are called to be deified the
you know that the Church Fathers always
kind of leave it up and say you know st.
Maximus the Confessor always says to the
extent that that's possible that's
always this the phrase he uses kind of
leaving it up to like I don't know
exactly how far how far it goes I think
you said maintaining the creature
uncreated creature
distinction but that this is kind of
full participation of the of creation
itself in the life of God shining forth
fully being fully united with with its
creator in a way that we can't fully
contain and I think that that mystery of
how the mother of God there's this this
this vacillation between the imagery of
wisdom between Christ himself
and his mother is pointing to me to that
eschatological possibility and that's
kind of how I see it that's kind of how
I resolve it in in my in my mind at
least I like that and but and the thing
is I think what I the other thing at
going back to something we were
suggesting in early this mystery is
really that you you came to all of this
by making the art right this is very
this is a very visual mystery always and
and that's I find that I mean this is
where Protestants I think you know
struggle right it's like you can't do
this just with words that much of it is
only accessible to us in the visual
representations the kinds of things the
kinds of images that you work with and
that you make because it's once you show
it it's like the throne of wisdom images
right it captures that entire mystery
and then you have to meditate on and
talk about it and encapsulate it but
there's there's something in the the
visual representation that does go
beyond what we're able to talk about um
although as I said in the in the Liturgy
it's it's also represented in the in the
chant right so the framing can could the
frightening can take place in words and
in sound but it it's unique both
visually and the oral I think to capture
the fullness of how hard it is to think
what does it mean that he entered into
his work I guess yeah and I think that
that's really the thing and there are
some things which it's so funny because
there are some things which which you
would if you say they become untrue as
soon as you say them mm-hmm you know
that and I and I really think you know I
think about for example the the the idea
that we're called to be united with God
to participate
God to be full of God to the extent that
that we can attain that but if you say
as soon as you say I am deified or I am
as soon as you say that that he comes
untrue because right not and then it
becomes a grabbing onto your own
prideful thing and so even the
difference between and the difference is
really the difference between Eve
reaching up and grabbing the fruit for
herself and the mother of God who in her
in her humility and in her her kind of
willingness to just say yes and to just
say yes to to this this this amazing
thing that was happening to her and to
almost be in to even be effaced in the
story in the Gospel story she's quite a
face there are few mysteries mysterious
I think there are a few really key
verses that that are if you read them if
you kind of pierce into them you
actually see that there's something else
going on but that that's the difference
and that's why and I think that that's
why that's the difference between Eve
and Mary's that in a way in a way that
the fruit was given to to Mary the fruit
that that Eve wanted to take from the
tree was given to to the mother of God
and her humility of knowledge and the
fruit of life was given to her and
that's that's what the Incarnation is
it's like she is this flip side of what
happened to at in the beginning she kind
of resolves she resolves in the
Incarnation the whole question of how we
can participate in God how we can be
given to be united with God and what
does that mean what does that look like
we should talk about the feminine imager
yeah all right okay
so I'm very very interested in in the
video you did on with symbolism and
propaganda the you were reading the
inversions of the feminine care that
that that pattern of inversions that's
showing up in the superhero movies yeah
where the women are you know that you
put women in the role of the masculine
heroes
Yeah right yes and it's a huge problem
and I liked I liked the way you it shows
it's like we need to watch for these
patterns because that's when we start
seeing where the symbolism is most
active and I mean are we assuming your
viewers have seen that video or do we
want to talk it I would say probably of
all the videos that I've ever walked it
ever made probably we can assume that
that video has been watched by whoever
is watching this I think and some movies
that I haven't seen in towers and things
like that
and the Wonder Woman is the one
exception but I think what your analysis
was actually very astute there where she
has to take out the church that I hadn't
thought of that one but this this this
curious need to take a masculine role
and simply stick a woman in it and then
say look we've you know empowered women
I think that's nonsense I think it's
ridiculous and the more I start seeing
it the more well I'm fine I mean disgust
as an interesting response right I'm
finding I find the humiliation of the
men for the elevation of these women
into the masculine roles profoundly
disturbing right it's really really
awful and I think it's it's it's it's
the Milo it's what he was trying to say
about the Ghostbusters movie right it's
like they're they're not female
character they're not feminine
characters they're just women and
masculine dress and what I find
interesting is that's one of the things
that in the past used to be a criticism
of there's this famous phrase in the
knot and I think it's in the Gospel of
Thomas it's one of the gnostic gospels
that this shouldve famous you know i go
who the gospels that's church then it
won and well one of them was one of them
is saying when Christ says when Jesus
says to the Apostles when they're
complaining about Mary being there and
it's a little it's a little ambiguous
whether it's Mary the mother mother of
Jesus or whether it's Mary Magdalene or
one of the other Mary's and and and
Jesus says to them well that's okay I'll
make her man yeah and then she can be
saved and everybody goes ah and the
thing is they're right to say ah because
we don't I mean women don't need to
become
yeah in order to be um you know
transformed in because we're already
made in the image and likeness of God
that's the great mystery of Christianity
how is it that he's we are made male and
female in the image and likeness of God
and what does that that you know pairing
of masculine and feminine actually mean
and I think you know that's what I'm
starting to realize that all of the work
that I did in my first book on the Song
of Songs it's the relationship between
the masculine and the feminine that's
what that book is about it's about the
mystery of the relationship between the
masculine and the feminine yeah and what
happens is I mean this has been my my
understanding is that what actually
happens in that equation is a strange
phenomena where it's actually the
feminine which suffers the most in it
yes is this idea that you know in order
to be important in order in order to
have value then you have to have these
masculine characteristics and then all
the private you know the the private
sphere the the all the traditional
feminine qualities are actually seen as
somewhat degraded somewhat you know
useless early they're destroyed yeah and
then that there is this you know yeah
anyway so IIIi think that there's a lot
of room for seem like there's a lot of
room right now for people who would want
to tell some good stories okay so what
I've been thinking right I also you I
know I I can't remember who you're
talking to in this video but you talked
about the domestic right the mother
makes the home and and we did a we did a
video in three craters with one of our
guests where he does house renovations
at Impala Veen and we talked
specifically about that imagery of the
home being associated with the mother
the grandmother and you start realizing
it's like no wonder everybody's
miserable right we have no homes anymore
because the woman isn't in the home and
you know there we have all these sort of
tropes and jokes and in our culture
about oh you need the gay the queer eye
for the house renovations Adams gay too
but that was another that was another
video that we did it's like talking
about his his his adventures as a
conservative in the game
that that we recognize the necessity of
making a home and yet devalued it
completely saying oh women should be out
in the workplace and what they did in
the home is is degrading to them and
it's like how is that possible you have
done is degrade the feminine not elevate
women and you culture right it's it's if
you don't if you cannot value the way in
which mothers create this space for
their husbands to go out into the into
the workplace and be strong and and and
and if productive for their children to
be nurtured and and and challenged and
and and cherished and given courage to
go out into the world this is I mean I
know you're friends with Jordan but this
is what I think he's gotten completely
wrong that he created he's sort of
focused on this image of woman as chaos
that the man then has to order it's like
no no there's there's feminine chaos and
feminine order there's masculine chaos
and masculine order and the feminine
order is exactly what Mary is embodying
for Christ right she is the place from
which he goes out into the world the
ordering structure I mean that's why
she's all of those images of creation
because she is literally the ordered
cosmos right that he takes takes body in
and then if you think about that that
the the wonderful the marriage of Cana
is just like my favorite story of ever I
mean they're all the Marion's stories
are wonderful but so he's there they're
at the marriage they're at a wedding
right there at the joining of a man and
woman to make a home so that there be
children so that there'll be you know
heroes and and and and and you know
daughters and sons that go out into the
world and daughters making their own
home and Mary is the one nudging him to
say you know they have no wine and I
love his response to it's like you know
and it's read in a lot of ways in the in
the exegesis like woman it's not my time
and you could just feel the sudden
saying that to his mother not yet mom
but on the other hand you know she needs
that little nudge to go into his his
role as you know the Savior and
performing the signs and there's I think
in that that that that exchange between
the tumors is like
the most the most wonderful moment of
real human interaction between a mother
and a son but also the cosmic reality
that it's the feminine that gives the
masculine the the space to become hero
within right and so I think that we have
somehow managed to degrade motherhood I
mean that abortion is like Oh women has
a right to choose to murder her child
what are you thinking that you have made
women into monsters by defining their
femininity on the basis of their their
their ability to kill that's just it's
it's mind-boggling to me no I totally
agree I think one of the things you said
now it's very important when you talked
about how there is this the way also
that Jordan talks about you know like
ordering chaos and how order is
masculine and feminine it's chaos and I
think that that it is obviously far more
subtle than that and and the way that we
see it I think that the basic structure
of heaven and earth that we find in the
beginning of Genesis is a is a good way
to do it because it is that let's say
you could say order and potential I like
potential better than chaos has such a
negative sentiment like order and
potential but then I think a us it's
real though I think I'd like to talk
about that a bit but go on the thing is
that order actually happens in between
that's it that's one of the difficult
things that I think that that Jordan
kind of gets wrong in terms of I mean
it's fine that what he does it but he
gets wrong it's not that it's not that
you have the city and you have the
outside of the the city which is chaos
it's more like you have this axis in the
center which is let's say that it's a
like a connection to heaven or
connection to identity a connection to
to your name all that and then you have
potentiality and what happens in between
is order order is the proper joining of
feminine and masculine as I love that
okay so that's when you see so the city
can have had the city as always
represented as feminine because it is
the space in which in which the ordering
happens
but it's also like the the particular
questions the particular problems of of
establishing an order you know the
questions it's like how do we do this
how do we do that
we put it here do we put a roof or how
like what is it that we're going to do
and then the the the the let's say the
name which answers those those
particulars and the interaction between
those two is what actually creates what
we'd call ordered space and I think that
that's a that's a far more it's a former
accurate way to understand it it's also
it's a it's more closer to the biblical
image because heaven isn't doing
anything and earth isn't doing anything
it's when the name starts to come down
you know when God speaks down into earth
and then calls forth earth to produce
it's the earth that produces he you know
it's not so earth does participate in
this gathering together you know to kind
of answer the to - to answer to the name
of what God is saying like let the earth
produce you know trees and it's like the
earth is the one is the one that
produces the trees so this it's this
interaction so it really is more that
there is like that that's when you can
really see it differently that it's the
kind of the sexual union between heaven
and earth which creates the child which
creates this this yes so that this is
fertile right this is this is fertile
ordering and and that's you know that
though that you need the the couple in
the home right you need the masculine
and the feminine in order for there to
be children that it's it's a and this
the the the mystery and I think I mean
Christianity I think understands this
beautifully right that you and you're
talking about Ephesians 2 in one of your
lectures that you know that the the way
in which we are bride and bridegroom
with God as soul and and and God but the
the masculine and the feminine odda
lling that because it's only with that
balance and and well I think we're
ordering that we actually end up with
fertility right and otherwise what
you're talking about with the inversion
the phim those women in the stories that
become the soldiers and the men who are
humiliated again I cannot I cannot tell
you how disgusting those images of men
being made small are to me I I despise
them I will not go see movies anymore
because nothing happens but that some
and you know I'm a fighter right I'm a
fighter in other ways right I've you
know fought for Milo you know for the
last two years I'm a fencer I know what
fighting is I am NOT a woman who thinks
you know the one I do want the man to
come rescue me because I do but on the
other hand that there is that there's a
there's a proper supportive role that
both of them play that has nothing to do
with these that the characterizations
that are in these these contemporary
movies where the the man is a terrible
father what what is the point in in in
you know the Incredibles with him not
being able to take care of the children
that's ridiculous fathers are perfectly
well you know that you need them to be
nurturing and and encouraging and you
know the dads are always the ones that
throw the babies up in the air and give
them you know the sort of taste of
adventure right where the moms are going
oh no you need both of them
you need the mother sitting there going
don't be you know be careful dear and
you dad going read and and those are
both parenting roles and somehow we've
we've turned it into this you know one
or the other that's ridiculous
you you need both both both modes in
order for the child to flourish and for
their for their to be daughters and sons
that are empowered and strong and
capable no I agree I agree and I think
that that's and I think that that that
maybe it would be interesting I now that
we've been actually talking about this
and kind of this idea of this of the the
union of the two in the relation with
the two I'm thinking I probably will I
probably will maybe make a video on that
directly because I think that that we've
hit on something that to simply
represent lis talk about order and chaos
as let's say an actual city or a
manifestation is order and at the
outside it's chaos I think it misses it
misses the essential part which is that
the city is the joining of heaven and
earth it's the joining of yes that's why
it's that have been visible order and
actual potato actual particulars and
lovely and and this is that I did a
course last year on
cities and towns and one of the things
in the Middle Ages and one of the things
we talked about was the symbolism of
city planning and in the period and
because I'm also I haven't you know sort
of what my new big new project is now
that I worked on prayer for 15 years I'm
working on virtues and vices but
specifically virtues and vices in the
city right in this Inn because the city
is the place where human beings live
right now like that nature is is in in
conversation with the city but cities or
human habitations right and for the
medieval city mary is at the center
there like the cathedral that's no true
dom is our lady in the middle right is
and the city forms around the cathedral
the city literally cathedrals are the
place where the bishop is so a city is
technically the bishop seat but the city
forms around the cathedral and the
cathedral is an image of Our Lady
because in the Cathedral in the church
God becomes present right so it's it the
the whole architecture of medieval
cities is premise on the ordering around
this twinning of God and creech creation
God and creature Marian and Christ know
I agree and I think that you know that's
when you start to understand some of the
imageries of like for example that the
in Constantinople when there were
problems they would they would parade an
icon of them whether God on the wall
like around and the mother of God is
seen as the protect protect protectress
of the city there is images called the
the protecting veil where you see you
see the mother of God standing and she
holds her veil or over the people and
she's kind of covering the people with
her veil and you see that Syrian it's
the m'f Orion right yeah yeah you see
the same image in the West but more you
see are holding out her her cape and you
see all these people inside her cape
kind of like you know this mother hand
it has all these people inside her her
cape and so you really do see that that
image of the feminine as this kind of
gathering in this you know the wall
around or or or and that's why I always
tried to help people understand that
that the relationship between masculine
and feminine
happens at many levels right this like
you said what you said it was perfect
like the center of the city has let's
say the spire and you have this idea
that they have a divine ray that would
come down like like this divine
manifestation the glory of God which
descends on on the the Holy of Holies
and and that is in Christianity like the
Eucharist the altar the the invisible
transformation that happens in the in
the Eucharist but then it's also it also
has so it has this masculine ray that
descends you could call it but it also
has this face which is the feminine
space which you need my or that to be
seen and then exactly right so then you
can go out and you have on the wall the
wall you have an aspect of the wall
which is the protective aspect which is
a holding in then you also have an
aspect of the wall which is the warrior
standing with is with this bow and art
with this bow and arrow shooting the
enemy is on the outside and right that's
the masculine aspect which is you know
and a fighting beating off the the
darkness and so each each layer has this
joining of masculine and feminine you
know and every and every that's a point
of the way and when you start to see it
that way it's okay to understand it
primarily as just this first opposite
like heaven and earth and this kind of
masculine feminine and this normal
opposite but you have to understand that
the world I talk about this all the time
the world is that is microcosm with in
microcosm within micro-fine and so so
every part has that for it to exist it
needs to have a joining of heaven and
earth and every level of the
manifestation of the city let's say yes
and that one of the things that I find
have always found most frustrating about
all modern discussion of masculine and
feminine imagery is it refuses that
that's necessary interaction it's like
the Eric Newman's book on the Great
Mother is there's a lot of Marian
imagery in there and he makes some major
mistakes right there's I did a blog post
about this and I have a page on my blog
fencing bare at prayer that the lady in
the logos and I've done a number of
posts about this this problem of the
Marian imagery that Noah in his great
mother suggests that Christian
doesn't carry this imagery and every
single image that he's invoking of the
mother as you know vessel and container
and space and oh they're all Marian
right but he just somehow didn't know it
and and that's been it's sort of curious
feature of modern discussions of the
medieval an Orthodox tradition of
devotion to Mary it's like they're blind
they have no understand they're and
they're they don't understand that the
feminine is you know in an interaction
with the masculine and the way we've
been talking about and that the wisdom
is interaction you know it's not just
body woman is not just body she's with
she's contemplation she's knowledge so
it's the either/or problem is it's been
frustrating me for my career that it
eliminates the complexity because then
when you end up looking you end up
looking at stories and people don't
understand it's like why do you have
Artemis who's the who's the the goddess
Huntress like just a mist it's Noah that
that you have to be able to see these
pairing of matthan feminine at all
levels and in all aspects of reality
where there is an aspect of the hunt and
you see like Artemis is also the
protector of the the young the protector
of the animal young which is like that's
interesting because a hunter would want
to protect the young because the hunter
wants to keep hunting and so and all of
a sudden you see this other aspect of
hunting which is you know the duck
Preservation Society and right so the
hunter isn't just the one shooting the
animals he's also the one protecting the
animals at the same time and so you see
in the mystery of Artemis you can see
how things are always more subtle than
we tend to want to think so I think that
is the deck so that's an excellent
example because the reason there's so
many deer in the United States is the
hunters have made sure there are that
you you you care for the population
because you understand them as creatures
and so I think that that's that's maybe
sometimes it's the danger sometimes of
the symbolism and and I can take some
blame for that when I try to talk in
broad categories and and in broad
structures to help people see the
structures right away but it's important
to be able to then dive into that and
see how you know it's it's just like
wine you know simple thing
like wine you know you you you drink
wine and then all of a sudden when you
get used to it you start to see all
these subtle you subtle tastes and these
subtle things that are happening that
aren't right there at the first at the
first glance but if you're not practiced
in doing it people think you're crazy
that's right and that's know that that's
that's what happens this is my drinking
wine so I it's my role to keep my chiny
Milo because he's my best example of a
lot of things but that I started writing
about the ways in which he was
performing a lot of this this imagery in
his talks and and you know and I
compared him to Jesus because you do in
the sense that I recognized him not just
talking about the patterns but
performing them right so that they're
there ways in which he was you know
traveling around the country and his
tour bus and so he's like Jesus
collecting followers and there's a bunch
of guys and they're traveling around
he's giving talks and that pisses me off
and then he gets you know his career
destroyed and oh wait you know exactly
what story are we in that you you you
start you start seeing the patterns that
we are living and and I think one of the
things you've been trying to show in
your talks is we live these stories
right once you are sort of a true
conversion as Augustine tells it in his
on catechizing is you recognize yourself
in the story right you Christians
recognize themselves in the whole
history of creation and salvation and
you should start seeing ways in which
the famous passage from the Lord of the
Rings Frodo and Sam recognized we're in
the same story right we're in this
pattern we are living this pattern
constantly which then gets us to the the
other thing that I wanted to bring up in
the masculine and feminine that that we
are we are what the imitation of Christ
or the imitation of Mary means is you
start recognizing them as the pattern
for human life and understanding what
Mary and Jesus's interactions show us
about the proper relationship between
the masculine and the feminine and this
goes back to what you were meditating on
the Marian Eve story right so hold on
we're getting there
you you mentioned and and this is one of
the one of the stories that I have liked
Jordans
interpretation of the beating the beasts
story so that the the Matt the feminine
hero here the feminine story for the
heroine is taming the Beast that's
that's good right that the indeed the
feminine a proper relationship of a wife
to a husband is is both encouraging him
and domesticating him right um George
Gilder has talked about this well in men
and marriage and he uses that beauty in
the B story to write the the sort of
Princess and the Barbarian that you have
the guy outside the city who is you know
hunting and making conquests and things
and she by it's a very interesting sort
of problem is saying the young man who
asks a woman to marry him is in effect
surrendering to her that's why he kneels
in our in our tradition kneels to her
it's also a worship of it's also married
right it's a it's a serving of Mary as
lady right and so you kneel to the lady
and say I I want to serve you and she
accepts him and by making that surrender
to her he is willing to be brought into
her home right which you can think about
it's like a lot of guys don't like
giving that up right they like you know
having their own independence and their
their you know they can play video games
or I think video games are actually good
we do we don't need to that that's not a
bad thing but it's it's guy things right
and and and there's always that trope of
you know the band of young men the frat
boys and stuff one of them finds a
girlfriend that's hard for the band of
men because he's gonna be drawn into her
world now and domesticated and made you
know yeah less beast like that's right
starts to shave it starts to shave
dresses right you know and that's good
because she is ennobling him right she
is giving him character and purpose if
they have children he gets to be a
patriarch right you don't get to be a
patriarch unless you have kids
fatherhood is good in Nobles and and and
dignifies men but there's another story
that nobody's mentioning you know what
it is yes I'm waiting with bated breath
I'm like what is there
go ahead The Taming of the Shrew right
of course yeah we're and that is what I
mean that is what Milo has been talking
about right feminism is cancer because
these women are shrews Yeah right
they're shrill they're ugly they are you
know refusing the authority of a man
quite directly but what they're doing is
refusing to respect that relationship
they are I mean it's a funny ending it's
funny in the story right that in the
play
katherine kate becomes tame but she was
an awful person before that right there
is real feminine vice which is is the
the kind of thing that that you know
Milo has been trying to point to that
it's real that women can be awful to men
and I think that that is my god because
they're human beings I mean my goodness
we're both right so there's no and
that's I mean it is a problem when you
make the feminine the source of all
virtue we're we're also Eve right we're
all so disobedient we're also grasping
we're also Trixie we also lie we also
bear false witness I think you have an
example and and to have this this image
that's why it's both Mary and Eve right
it's it's just like it's both Adam in
Christ the the virtue and vice are
something that both men and women need
to to have models for and work for and
it's it's wrong to put the woman in the
place of being the only virtue just as
it's the wrong to put the man in the
place of the only heroism that's not our
relationship with God it's it's it's
that we are and the the great mystery is
of course that Mary when god says to her
you know you're to become the mother
says yes right and that's that's that
that that is the quintessential moment
of the man kneeling before her right
angel is often shown in the in the
iconography of the Annunciation coming
and kneeling before Mary well that's a
pretty interesting image God kneels
before his mother and she accepts him
and then that the twinning is is of
course in the Western iconography that
she is then assumed into heaven crowned
by him and boughs to him all of these
gestures of wreck
Nishan and obedience are incredibly
powerful and incredibly important yeah
no III told agree I think though I
always tell people that we are right now
this that with kind of the crazy a lot
of the problems that we're having now
the feminism and and a lot of the kinda
intersectional attitude we're also
paying for something that started a long
time ago I mean we I think we're we're
it's the pendulum swing from the
Enlightenment
it's the pendulum swing from a world
where only reason has value where only a
certain type of knowledge a certain type
of action where we're conquering was the
only virtue and we lost the medieval
balance that you talk about between
between this this kind of the
relationship between a you know a knight
who is strong and who is who you know
who who goes to war and is able to
protect his country but who also kneels
his lady and is also is also making no
gold by his relationship with his lady
and so that that that balance was
definitely lost and now we've got the
other side where is this we we've been
telling people the only thing that has
value is this this kind of rationalistic
vision of the world and so women are
saying well okay well then i want that
like i'm gonna if that's the only thing
that has value then i'm going to take
that and sadly except for what
interestingly they're doing it in this
well Freudian terms hysterical way yeah
right that they're doing it with emotion
completely uncontrolled they're not even
behaving rationed all of the stuff i
mean i was thinking about the Kavanagh
hearing obviously that all of the stuff
around you know that this the what and
there's a number of people have been
writing about this Tony Allen has
written quite passionately about it and
quite perceptively about it recently in
new English review and Christopher Groot
has been writing about it the need for
masculine Authority and and and the the
real effect of having so many women in
the public sphere what we've become
every caricature there ever was about
women it's it's you know they're
hysterical they're overly emotional they
they can't you know think it's like and
and they're you know when you have a
supreme you know a proper you know
structured
national judicial here in for you know
figuring out whether or not this person
is appropriately qualified to be a
Supreme Court justice and people
screaming outside the doors banging on
them have you have you lost your minds
ladies you are behaving like every worst
caricature you say was the misogynistic
literature the Middle Ages
well the misogynistic miniature of the
Middle Ages also included images of Mary
right and it's like that that literature
what you've been doing is saying well
every bad WA image of women is not real
and it's like well then stop behaving
like them all right I I'm really tempted
to say okay mom okay mom I think that
that we we got the message and listen
III I think we I think we had a good
conversation we've been going for a
while and I think that that last that
last message from Rachel I hope it goes
viral
well Rachel thank you so much for
talking to me I really enjoyed it I
actually felt like we break we broke
some interesting ground in in kind of
showing some of the problems that in the
way that things have been let's say
represented in the in the past few years
and I think that there's a lot to talk
about and hopefully we'll have a chance
to do it again and I and I wish you I
know we didn't talk about all your your
kind of difficulties and everything but
I do wish you got what you know I know
I'm just saying I wish you the best and
I and I pray that that you that you will
you always remain on top of the fray and
then you'll continue on as you are right
now well I have I mean with people that
you're wondering about you know strong
women and and great battle warrior
warrior is's Mary forgetting a sake
she's looking keister daughter she's
she's you know the you talked about her
new they parade her parade they process
her icon on the walls of Constantinople
to save the city you don't need any
other warrior got you know warrior woman
you got Mary all right Rachel so so so
thanks again and so hi everybody I will
I will see you soon thank you if you
enjoyed this content and our exploration
of symbol
get involved I love to read your
insights and questions in the comments
section you can also share this video on
social media to your friends and as you
can please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below